he isn't hi We're Jennifer rostock we  want to wish you dear pop export all the  best for the next 100,000 years happy  birthday on a kiss from us useful xq  exported dear pop export fans with a  killer pizza and we want to congratulate  you on your 10th anniversary even if all  these fingers add up to 30 we're very  happy you've been broadcasting for 10  years promoting German music and that  means us too so we'd like to thank you  from the bottom of our hearts yeah  congratulations pop export on deutsche  welle TV all the best from the Western  storm and exile and lots of love to pop  export on your 10th 10 years that's  quite a while here's to the next 10  years keep playing great music we'll be  watching you hey pop export is turning  10 for the past 10 years pop export has  been showcasing bands from Germany  letting people around the world know  what's going on in this beautiful  country